the pandemic is forcing many families to
change christmas plans this year
but some traditions will continue last
year we met a new york family that holds
the guinness book of world records for
the most
holiday lights on a residential property
look at that this year
the home has even more lights nearly 670
000 of them in the family's
drive-through show
jamie wax is in new orleans with another
display that will go on this year with a
little inspiration from the past
jamie so good to see you good morning
good to see you jerica good morning new
orleans is celebrating 35 years of one
of the most spectacular holiday light
displays in the country
this morning we're taking you on a ride
through more than one
million lights each of them shining a
little bit of normalcy
tradition and joy on what's been a very
difficult year
there's no snow but it's certainly
lovely weather for a car
ride in new orleans
[Music]
this is the long-running holiday lights
festival known as celebration in the
oaks
this year's display features one million
one hundred sixteen
thousand seven hundred likes along a two
and a quarter mile long
path and for the first time in 15 years
the celebration isn't a walking tour but
a driving one
early on when we realized what the
pandemic was going to do
and the restrictions that were going to
be we pivoted city park ceo
bob becker expects 200 000 people will
visit the festival this season
it's a beautiful idea 200 000 people
sharing a holiday experience
that is also safe and isolated give
people a chance
to celebrate this season have a great
experience
but do it safely
growing up the holiday lights in new
orleans were a fixture in our traditions
i remember piling into the way way back
of my family station wagon and watching
the show march across the back
windshield
for most of its early history you could
take in celebration and the oaks from
the comfort of your car
city park looks like a lagoon then in
2005
the category 5 hurricane katrina tore
through new orleans
leaving devastation in its wake city
park was annihilated we lost every
building
most of the staff all our equipment 2
000
trees the staff rallied to create a new
tradition
in just a couple of months the festival
was reborn
with holiday revelers on foot for the
people who poured into city park
christmas comes with a new meaning this
year we are resilient people here
and we've been through a lot we
understand what it means to come back
and to hang in there and the hang tough
2020 is forcing us all to become more
resilient
one tradition at a time all across
america
in duluth minnesota the bentleyville
tour of lights is morphing from one of
the largest free walking tours in the
country
to a drive-through and in texas
a decades-long neighborhood lights
festival that prides itself in keeping
austin weird
is cancelled to protect the block's
elderly and at-risk
residents want me to help you blow it i
believe that when we go through
something
jamie we come out of it
not poorer but richer beloved new
orleanian former wwl tv anchor sally ann
roberts
knows the value of resilience do you
find a silver lining in the fact that
this is once again a drive-through
experience it's the tonic that we need
right now
to be able to allow our children to
experience what we experience as
children
and they're listening to holiday music
in their cars right now
and just celebrating the season
celebrating what we have
there are a lot of things that we have
lost but we still have
our loved ones here it's not hard to see
the light at the end of the tunnel
it's everywhere to still have the kids
celebrate
see their smiles light up on their faces
despite the pandemic has been great
the whole time they've been non-stop
mommy look at this daddy look at this
this is the season of love this is the
season
of family and this is the season where
we can just be grateful for what
we have and know that better days are
ahead
for cbs this morning jamie wax new
orleans
and in addition to the much-loved
displays that are traditional here like
mr bingle
behind me there are some new displays
debuting this year including
a very fitting tribute to our health
care workers vlad
all right jamie thank you very very much
for that what a wonderful piece
i don't believe the hype when people
tell you that you know we're divided
that things are worse than they've ever
been you see a story like that and what
sally ann roberts said
the tonic we need oh yeah i like that so
good to see her
yeah i feel like the lights there's like
a child
curiosity and wonder to it you know
childlike that you can just
yeah it brings it back to feeling good